[Aplausos]
não fui convidado a ser um dos speakers
e texel do sul
eu fiquei imaginando que ouviria falar
aqui hoje para vocês como eu venho de
uma formação na área das ciências
econômicas
logo imaginei falar sobre planejamento
financeiro algo que corriqueiramente eu
falo nas minhas palestras
porém passado alguns dias do convite e
tendo em vista a minha trajetória a de
pesquisa acadêmica tanto no mestrado
quanto doutorado
resolvi falar sobre a participação
social sobre planejamento territorial
sobre o direito à cidade
esta é uma reflexão que eu quero fazer
com vocês e eu peço que a gente faça em
conjunto embora neste momento apenas eu
esteja aqui falando mas nós estamos
conectados a partir de vontades a partir
de sentimentos
visando então começar essa nossa
conversa é essa a nossa reflexão eu
quero fazer três perguntas pra vocês
qual é a cidade que nós temos
qual é a cidade que nós queremos ter
e qual é a cidade que nós podemos ter
talvez todos tenham alguma resposta ou
respostas para estas perguntas
talvez alguns não estejam entendendo
onde o queira chegar com esta relação
entre planejamento territorial e o
direito à cidade
eu vou facilitar então a vida de todo
mundo
eu vou fazer uma outra pergunta de uma
outra forma eu gostaria que cada um de
vocês aqui mentalizar-se essa resposta
ou as respostas que possivelmente também
poderão aparecer consigo ea partir dela
nós vamos desenvolver a nossa linha de
raciocínio até o final da minha
apresentação
o que eu mudaria na cidade em que eu
vivo certamente muitos ou todos
responderam alguma coisa eu gostaria que
ocorresse uma alteração na rua
eu moro eu gostaria que na cidade em que
eu vivo tenha mais arborização
eu gostaria que na cidade em que eu vivo
tem uma economia melhor tem uma vida
política melhor
ou seja nós temos vontades e desejos
para as nossas cidades
falo em cidade o que é uma cidade né
o que é uma cidade eu quero fazer esse
exercício com vocês eu quero que cada um
mentalize na sua cabeça o que é uma
cidade estava uma imagem de uma cidade
para sua cabeça
certamente muitos imaginaram uma cidade
dessa forma muitos prédios com muitas
casas com muitos carros ruas alguns
imaginaram até mesmo os sons e os aromas
que esta cidade produz estão todas
corretas
a cidade é isso cada um constrói a sua
cidade cada um vê a sua cidade da melhor
forma ou da forma como ela é dada como
ela é dadá mas e aí será que a cidade é
só isso não
a cidade é muito mais do que nós podemos
imaginar a cidade em princípio é formada
pelo rural e pelo urbano embora nós
pensemos que a cidade é apenas urbano
eu vou mais além a cidade é constituída
a partir de relações sociais relações
técnicas
vamos pensar no exemplo da ponte a ponte
por si só é uma construção é um conjunto
de elementos técnicos visando a passagem
de carros e bicicletas de pessoas mas em
cima da ponte existem pessoas embaixo da
ponte também existem pessoas existem
relações existem pessoas com sentimentos
com vontades constituindo o que nós
chamamos de território
a partir das relações
isto é há cidade a cidade é formada por
um conjunto técnico e um conjunto humano
de relações sociais e aí então nós
chegamos no conceito de sociedade o que
é uma sociedade no campo financeiro no
campo administrativo organizacional uma
sociedade com dois sócios se unem dois
ou três sócios se unem para formar um
negócio para ter lucro
uma sociedade do ponto de vista
antropológico
de acordo com norbert elias uma
sociedade é dada a partir de um conjunto
de relações de pessoas
sendo assim um conjunto de relações de
pessoas na china jamais vai constituir a
mesma sociedade
aqui em rio do sul ou em qualquer outra
cidade brasileira porque as pessoas são
diferentes porque as questões técnicas e
humanas são diferentes em diferentes
espaços ea então nós temos que entender
se nós pudermos olhar para esta cidade
com mais atenção nós conseguimos
entender e conseguimos perceber que
nossa cidade existe conflito existem
relações de poder
e aí nós chegamos no que nós chamamos de
território
o território é constituído por e para as
relações de poder
conflitos
talvez muitos já tiveram já presenciaram
conflitos na cidade seja indústrias
querendo se instalar em locais
inapropriados sejam maus sejam as
pessoas querendo se instalar em locais
inapropriados a exemplo das encostas de
morros são suscetíveis a riscos e
desastres
então nós temos conflitos constantes
conflitos
um é que nós vamos passar por estes
conflitos como é que nós podemos
melhorar a cidade em que eu vivo
ou seja como eu posso buscar o
desenvolvimento da minha cidade e aqui
faço um parêntese desenvolvimento
logo nos vem à cabeça de que algo
positivo
é algo bom mas não as nossas cidades a
partir das relações sociais e das
relações técnicas constituídas ao longo
do tempo se modificaram né se
modificaram este processo de
desenvolvimento sendo este uma mudança
no espaço e no tempo
pode ser positivo ou negativo e o que eu
quero
a partir das minhas pesquisas a partir
daquilo que eu posso contribuir e que eu
quero sensibilizá-los hoje aqui a também
fazer cada um do seu modo é constituir
um bom desenvolvimento dessas nossas
sociedades das nossas cidades e aí então
nós chegamos no direito à cidade o que é
o direito à cidade o direito à cidade
de acordo com o ief autor francês
ele diz que é o direito à cidade não
pode ser concebida apenas como um
direito de visita de vetor nas cidades
tradicionais ou seja ela não podemos
apenas visitar a cidade
nós temos que ter o direito à vida na
cidade
nós temos que ter o direito a uma cidade
transformada renovada como que nós vamos
então renovar uma cidade alguns elaboram
e desenvolvem projetos até mesmo embaixo
da ponte
e nós como podemos contribuir para o
processo de desenvolvimento da nossa
cidade e das nossas sociedades
participando
nós precisamos participar o que é
participar participar
de acordo com o dicionário tem 14
significados
porém eu lecionei 2 participar significa
tomar parte participar significa
compartilhar o que isso quer dizer
isso quer dizer que nós precisamos
compartilhar aquilo que nós pensamos e
aquilo que nós sentimos
aquilo que nós queremos para a cidade
onde nós vivemos
se nós não fizermos isso a cidade não
vai ter a nossa cara
nós vamos ter
ver e viver a cidade nós não vamos ter
prazer de ter vida naquela cidade
logo nove gramas e este é um fenômeno
que acontece diariamente então o
participar é extremamente importante
para as nossas cidades
tendo em vista essa perspectiva de
participação ea minha vontade de
participar no processo de planejamento
das cidades sendo o planejamento o
caminhar a partir de um determinado
caminho para atingir um determinado
objetivo
surge então o doutorado doutorado em
planejamento territorial e
desenvolvimento socioambiental
ingressei no programa da universidade do
estado de santa catarina
no segundo semestre de 2016 justamente
com essa proposta
com esta pergunta como nós podemos
participar em um processo de
planejamento territorial como que nós
podemos participar
visando né visando desenvolver esta
nossa cidade visando idéias que não
estejam fora dos lugares em lugares fora
das idéias e aí então em função da
umidade em função de toda a tecnologia
da informação e comunicação que está se
desenvolvendo todo o processo de
desenvolvimento no cyber espaço da saber
cultura eu resolvi entrar nessa pesquisa
de correlacionar planejamento
territorial e participação a partir do
contexto do cyber espaço
ou seja se nós formos analisar aqui hoje
dentre todos questão quem aqui não
possui celular
pouquíssimas pessoas ou nenhuma
todos estamos hoje hiperconectados nós
estamos hoje conectados com todas e aí
que reside a minha pesquisa eu quero
mostrar que a partir das nossas relações
hoje constituídas a partir de novos
elementos técnicos como por exemplo as
tecnologias da informação e comunicação
nós podemos compartilhar os nossos
desejos das nossas vontades ea nossa
forma
entender a cidade ea nossa forma de
contribuir para o processo de
planejamento territorial e por que é
importante participar
eu ouvi durante muitas vezes e muitas
reuniões com grupos de vereadores com
membros de núcleos gestores de
planejamento territorial das nossas
cidades e que a população não deveria
participar não deveria participar porque
ela não tem conhecimento técnico mas
peraí
a cidade é formada por relações sociais
também não apenas as relações técnicas
para que vocês possam entender a
importância do planejamento e da
participação no planejamento
vencemos na construção da nossa casa eu
particularmente não tenho conhecimento
da engenharia civil para poder
dimensionar a quantidade de cimento a
quantidade de areia de ferro para
construção da minha casa eu não tenho de
fato não tem esse conhecimento técnico
porém eu tenho desejos e vontades
eu quero tomar parte da construção dessa
casa eu quero e eu quero que ela que
essa casa tem a minha cara
eu quero que essa casa tenha três
quartos
eu quero que a casa seja arborizada eu
quero que a casa seja sustentável eu
quero um monte de coisa eu tenho desejo
eu idealizo uma casa e assim também nós
idealizamos uma cidade
o diferencial é que na construção de uma
casa eu até participo e na construção
das nossas cidades
nós participamos e aí então tendo em
vista a parte da minha pesquisa que
demonstra que nós não participamos
nós não tomamos parte e não
compartilhamos nossos sentimentos surge
a perspectiva da minha tese de doutorado
e correlacionar cyber espaço e
participação eu acredito que a
participação pode sim hoje ocorrer
através das tecnologias da informação e
comunicação porque nós estamos
interconectados
é fato hoje existem mais celulares no
brasil do que pessoas em torno de 240
milhões de aparelhos conectados
então nós estamos imersos nessa saber
cultura
na verdade nós criamos e nós constitui
saberi cultura e aí então fazendo as
minhas pesquisas de doutorado buscando
teorias buscando a relações buscando
informações sobre o processo de
planejamento territorial
eu encontrei o instituto politécnico de
torino na itália e também está
pesquisando há mais de duas décadas
planejamento territorial e participação
participei de um processo seletivo
visando um período de estudos junto a
pesquisadores do politécnico de torino
tive aprovação no meu projeto e de
câmbio daqui alguns dias estou indo
estudar novas formas de planejamento
territorial junto a pesquisadores do
instituto politécnico de torino visando
trazer para a nossa realidade trazendo
para os nossos dias e para as nossas
situações cotidianas
essa relação e demonstrar que nós
precisamos participar
se nós não participarmos nós não
constituiremos as cidades como nós
idealizamos nós vamos ter as cidades que
nós queremos nós não vamos ter as
cidades que nós podemos
muitos ela está pensando mas eu não
tenho tempo de participar
este é um dos elementos que mais
aparecem quando se pergunta por que você
não participa
a primeira resposta é falta de tempo a
segunda resposta é falta de informação
o celular está 24 horas praticamente a
nossa mão
por que então não usar essa ferramenta
para participar
a desculpa da falta de tempo já não vai
colar mais a desculpa da falta de
informação também não porque hoje a
internet está aí o chamado big data com
a grande quantidade de informações
disponíveis e nós precisamos reverter
essas informações em conhecimento
então eu sempre digo nós precisamos usar
e extrair as potencialidades positivas
das tecnologias da informação e
comunicação visando assim a nossa
participação social visando assim o
direito à cidade sendo a cidade também
entendida como uma obra é uma obra que
está em constante processo de
modificação uma obra
todos nós constituída e não é justo
deixar apenas alguns poucos dentro dessa
perspectiva de planejamento territorial
tecnicismo que nós temos hoje que apenas
alguns poucos decidem o que muitos
deverão seguir então no brasil hoje nós
temos o estatuto da cidade e nós temos
os planos diretores municipais
quem a conhece poucas pessoas conhecem a
base do nosso planejamento territorial
então nós precisamos buscar informações
e precisamos nos sensibilizar o que é
sensibilizar sensibilizar a entender né
entender que nós podemos contribuir com
um determinado processo
neste caso a entender que nós podemos
contribuir com o processo de
planejamento das nossas cidades nós
podemos construir um caminho para a
cidade que nós queremos a partir da
cidade que nós temos para isso nós
precisamos participar nós precisamos
tomar parte nós precisamos compartilhar
e não é preciso ter grande quantidade de
dinheiro para poder participar
a classe social não importa não é
preciso ter conhecimento técnico
específico para poder participar não é
preciso ser branco ser negros e pardos e
amarelo
não é preciso para participar basta ter
vontade para participar basta colocar a
cara para fora e dizer o que você quer
da cidade o que você espera na cidade em
que você vive e todos nós hoje podemos
fazer a partir até mesmo dos nossos
celulares como exemplo de participação
através de nossas tecnologias da
informação e comunicação 1 citar três
exemplos primavera árabe
as mobilizações são chamadas de cyber
ativistas ocorridas nos estados unidos o
chamado occupy wall street e também as
manifestações ocorridas em junho de 2013
no brasil
ou seja existe a constituição de novas
território
dá lhes a partir das redes sociais
virtuais e assim o direito à cidade
somente será alcançado quando
participarmos quando compartilhar os
nossos desejos e sobretudo os nossos
sonhos
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]